Amy Chua welcome to afterwards the the
title of your the subtitle of your new
book day of empire is how hyper powers
rise to global dominance and why they
fail and of course the United States is
the hyper power of the day so we
obviously have have a dog in this fight
so the first question I'd like to get
out of the way is really a definitional
one there's been lots and lots of Empire
talk these days I'm not sure that we
even know what an empire is I heard one
commentator not long ago saying empires
have as much in common as women named
Jane and now you're talking about a
subset of that called hyper powers so
could you first just take a minute and
explain to us you know what isn't what
is meant by Empire and then go on to the
second part what is this hyper power
that you're talking about
okay well I agree that Empire I don't
even know if it's worth it to try to
define it because people just use it all
different ways so my book actually
despite the title isn't specifically
about empires it really is about this
very much rare category hyper powers and
by a hyper power I mean not just great
powers not just superpowers but really
I'm referring to those relatively few
societies I mean there have been barely
more than a handful in history that
amassed such extraordinary economic and
military might and projected their power
over so vast an area of the globe that
they basically dominated the world upset
for example the United States during the
Cold War was not a hyper power because
it had a rival the former Soviet Union
of roughly comparable strength but let's
zero in there just a little bit further
at one point I think you you give us
three criteria that hyper powers need to
meet but I think would be helpful to
know just to get that out of the way
what are those three criteria well of
the biggest challenges I faced in
writing this book was how to define a
hyper power or a rural dominant power
precisely because the world was so much
larger
two thousand years ago before planes and
technology Frank it so the tough case
for me was actually Rome because if Rome
wasn't a hyper power then there's never
been a hyper power so no China right but
halfway across the world there was
another great empire han dynasty china
with which rome had virtually no contact
so basically the criteria i came up with
are one to be a hyper power one you have
to be a society has to clearly surpass
all of its known rivals in both economic
and military strength criteria two is
that the society can't be clearly weaker
militarily or economically to any other
power on the planet no to it or not for
example the Aztecs don't qualify under
this definition they were very powerful
in Central America but they were they
didn't remotely have the technology of
Europe and the third criteria is simply
one of scale that you really have to be
a private powers have to be those
societies that project their power over
so great a territory in so vast a
population that they you know that you
could really describe them as a global
hegemon or you know a world dominant
power not just a regional power right in
whatever their world happens to be right
and that world has to be significant
enough exactly because otherwise he is
not Tahiti I was saying you know you
could somebody could say well Tahiti
isn't Tahiti a hyper power in its own
little world and I thought you know any
definition that includes Tahiti as a
hyper power is too broad so I had to cut
him narrow it down okay so now we know
what a hyper power is and we know that
we are one right and in just a minute
I'm gonna come back to who some of these
other hyper powers were but one of the
great things about your book is that you
actually have a very clear thesis I mean
some books are wonderfully entertaining
simply because of the descriptive
narrative power and yours is is great
that way too but the but you have an
argument to make about about the rise
and fall of of hyper powers and this
comes in a long line of people who have
attempted you know great historical
theater
about why things happen in in history
and yours is fascinating so I wonder if
you could give us a kind of capsule
version of your core thesis okay well
first of all there are not very many
hyper powers in history so you know I
was looking for them and I was looking
for patterns things that connect them
and what I found was really a remarkable
and I think unvarying pattern and this
is the thesis which is that every single
hyper power in history was at least
judged by the standards of its time
remarkably tolerant and pluralistic on
its rise to dominance and in fact
tolerance in every case was
indispensable to the achievement of
rural dominance really the secret to
world dominance is tolerance conversely
the flipside of the pattern I found is
that the decline of hyper powers has
repeatedly coincided with intolerance
and xenophobia and calls for you know
ethnic and religious purity so that's
the basic phases ok I I want to come
back this idea of tolerance in just a
second because I have a feeling that
what you mean by tolerance and
intolerance isn't necessarily what
Americans mean by those words when we're
trying to live our lives in the 21st
century but maybe it's a little bit
premature so because I think listeners
may not be as surprised by the notion of
tolerance applied to certain societies
until they know what those societies are
so why don't you start by running
through the places that you think have
been hyper powers in history there's
what maybe half a dozen barely half a
dozen well the first hyper power in
history was the ancient a commended
Persian Empire founded in 550 BC by
Cyrus the Great I think most Americans
don't know that much about ancient
Persia but that was actually wrong
everybody gets it in first grade but but
in fact that Empire ruled an astonishing
one-third of the world's population so
it was really a hyper power it swallowed
up the great empires of Assyria
the Greek city-states Egypt and just
really you don't incorporated them just
moving a little quickly the second hyper
power over there was not another hyper
fire for another four hundred years
after that and in fact that was wrong
not so surprising and Tong dynasty China
and the seventh century was I think
China at its most powerful again an
empire that I think most Americans don't
know that much about my favorite case my
favorite hyper power is the great Mongol
Empire founded by jenga's Khan in the
13th century and this should be raising
some flags since I said that tolerance
is the secret to world dominance I'm
sure most people don't think of jenga's
khan as tolerant so those were the
pre-modern hyper powers and then moving
to the modern day another surprising
case I I think I think this is the
closer case but I suggest that the first
modern hyper power was the tiny Dutch
Republic of the 17th century after that
the British Empire again not a
surprising case and finally the United
States so really barely more than a
handful probably Americans do know a
little bit about the British Empire and
I don't think most Americans really know
much about despite what I said about
first grade about about all the others
it's a little bit more about Rome thanks
to some recent television programs I'd
love to hear more about all of these
places and I wonder if we could maybe
pick a couple of them to talk about you
said the Mongol was was one of your
favorites to talk about in terms of well
for instance tolerance and you mentioned
that Genghis Khan was not really coupled
in the American imagination with the
idea of tolerance so low you can imagine
how much worse he'd be if he'd been
intolerant but why don't you tell us
what do you mean by tolerance in the
context of your book great
so by tolerance I don't mean equality or
respect I'm not using tolerance in the
modern human rights sense rather by
tolerance I simply mean letting lots of
different kinds of people even if you
don't like or respect them work and
participate and prosper in your society
regardless of ethnicity skin color or
religion so it's really a relative
concept by tolerance I mean the degree
of freedom with which a society allows
people of all different kinds of
backgrounds to participate and and
prosper in society so it is what matters
is not whether a society is tolerant by
any kind of absolute standard but
whether it's more tolerant than its
rivals and let me just say why should
tolerance be the secret to you know
global dominance and it first it might
seem a little surprising but actually
the there's a very simple and I think
intuitive explanation and that is that
in order to be globally dominant you
know not just regionally or locally
dominant but really worl dominant a
society really has to be at the very
forefront of the world's economic and
technological and military development
and at any given time in history the
best human capital that the world has to
offer you know in terms of intelligence
and creativity and drive and enterprise
and networks and know-how the best human
capital that the world has to offer is
never going to be found within one
ethnic group or within one religious
group so to pull away from all your
rivals on a global scale a society
really has to pull in the best and
brightest from all over the world
regardless of ethnicity or religion or
you know linguistic background mm-hmm so
you make a good case for why tolerance
is this essential ingredient and in a
few minutes I want to come back to the
flipside to to intolerance but let's
stop on the Mongols for for a moment
since this is an opportunity to learn
something factual as well as to see how
it fits in with your theory you know the
Mongols for many people myself included
are really just a term a proper noun
tell us where did the Mongols come from
how did they become a hyper power and
then tell us something about how
tolerance fits in we for some how we do
have an image in our minds
just ordinary people of the Mongols as
having committed you know atrocities of
various kinds and the sack of this place
or the sack of that place and so there's
some of that is is in the picture so
could you just fill us in a little bit
more and by the way I love the the the
name that they had for themselves with
the people of the felt walls yes yeah
your yurts right yes yes
well again I find the map Mongols an
especially fascinating case again
because when I was a little I'm a
Chinese background this is not what I
knew of the Mongols I was also under the
impression well they've just you know
vicious barbarians and it is puzzling
how they conquered actually half the
known world so backing up the Mongols
were a nomadic people they lived on the
Mongol steps that is north of China they
were famous as barbarians everywhere and
in fact there's a reason for that
stereotype the Mongols themselves had
virtually no technology of themselves
they were because they were nomadic
people they had no agriculture they had
no architecture they lived in these
tents the yurts made of the felt of yaks
and they really had no engineering they
had no science in fact they didn't even
have the technology to bake bread so the
question is how did these long goals
overcome China and the great walled
cities dove Eastern Europe and the
Middle East and Persia I mean the
greatest cities of their day can you
remind just intro for one second can you
remind us how far the Mongol Empire
extended that it's and it's this is back
in the 13th century and at its peak the
Mongols actually ruled basically half
the known world so all of China much of
Persia much of the Middle East including
Baghdad Cairo Damascus all of Central
Asia and in fact they conquered Hungary
parts of Germany and they extended all
their reach all the way to the gates of
Vienna so it was a huge Empire the
largest continuous territorial Empire
far larger than the Romans ever
conquered so the question is how did the
the Mongols who themselves had no
technology do this
and the first thing that jenga's Kahn
did he was from the smallest step tribe
I mean really the lowest of the low they
were scavengers and what he first did
was he United the peoples of the steppe
in a way through tolerance at a small
scale because he said you know what we
are all one people we are people of the
felt walls instead of this tribe in this
tribe in this tribe we have a lot in
common and he actually created
inter-ethnic armies he put together
squadrons and it would be deliberately
mixed inter-ethnic Lee all religions and
one of the first things that jenga's
Kahn did when he actually conquered was
he declared freedom of worship for all
his peoples again that's something
surprising people don't think of that
but he himself was a very spiritual sort
of animist believed in nature but he
declared he was completely open to
Buddhists Christians Muslims so he put
together an inter-ethnic army big enough
to conquer northern China but that was
only the beginning the most brilliant
thing that jenga's khan did was he
recruited talented and skilled engineers
from the people he conquered most
importantly the Chinese he recruited
huge numbers of Chinese engineers who
knew how to build the most powerful
siege engines of the day so this is what
the Mongols did they recruited they
didn't kill off and extinguish and you
know enslave but they recruited and
treated very well allowed to rise these
people who had the skills that they
themselves didn't doctors scribes I mean
they themselves had no written language
so jenga's khan then incorporated these
engineers and scientists and map makers
and astrologers and that was how these
people traveled with the mongols and
they often would just build these siege
engines right on the spot they would
arrive they would cut down trees and
build great catapults and that could
sort of hurl explosives and retractable
ladders and portable towers sort of Lord
of the Rings kind of thing and it was
only in that way that they overcame the
you know really greatest cities of their
day so
so I see how the tolerance plays in here
along with a certain amount you have to
admit of intolerance on the on the
fringe well it's funny because my
definition is simply letting lots of
different kinds of people participate
and rise and even if it's only for
instrumental reasons so yes there was
lots and lots of intolerance by our
modern definitions you know they did not
respect human life they were not
observers of you know human rights as we
know it but in fact they were very
colorblind the Mongols were really
colorblind and religiously open in that
sense much more so for example than
Europe at the time right I've got the
picture you know have you noticed how
often things seem to stop at the gates
of Vienna
I wondered why that was the case did the
did the Mongols for all the the
absorptive capacity that they had and
their willingness to to use people and
ideas wherever they they found them
today themselves ever develop a society
that became organically vibrant this way
or not no they did not and this actually
has to do with the story of the downfall
and the Mongols because partly they had
no culture of their own when fascinating
thing that happened is that they took on
the cultures of the people that they
conquered so for example the Mongol
rulers of Russia and Persia converted to
Islam and unfortunately within a very
short time they relinquished the
religious tolerance that jenga's khan
had practiced and they became
increasingly fanatic in their
persecution of non-muslims particularly
of Christians and Buddhists and I think
that was a huge part of how those parts
of the Empire disintegrated most
interestingly I think was China the
Mongols famously Kublai Khan conquered
China and instead of trying to crush
Chinese civilization Kublai Khan loved
Chinese civilization he embraced it in
fact I think he was more tolerant of
Chinese literature and opera than many
other Chinese rulers he really
cultivated it and it was fascinating in
my book I described how
he surrounded himself with Chinese
advisors and Confucians and Buddhists
but within the imperial palace the
mongols still slept in tents they still
slept of a drank yak milk and they slept
in yurts within sight inside the palace
so there was a certain amount of it was
only a partial absorption of the Chinese
culture but during its Golden Age the
Mongol were very very tolerant of
Chinese culture and again the decline
was just the opposite that's fascinating
the the other hyperpower which is a
little bit more familiar to Americans is
the Dutch Empire but a little doesn't
mean a lot and you have some some
wonderful writing about the the Dutch
Empire you talk about how if you could
smell it it would smell like beer and
tobacco you talk about the the great
spirit of capitalism that animated the
Dutch and I wonder if just if you could
quickly give us a portrait of the of the
Dutch and then I want to move to America
which is the hyper power that we happen
to live in okay well first I should back
up for just one second because I want to
say that the role of tolerance has
changed over time which is one of the
most interesting things I found about
the book the way that what it takes to
be a hyper power has changed so in the
old days in ancient times
why was tolerance important well
basically tolerance was the only way
that you could build a the largest army
in the world right power was all about
having the most number of soldiers so if
for example as with the Greeks if you
limit your army to only pure blooded
Spartans then your army is only going to
be so big it's gonna be inherently
limited but if you open up your military
to the best warriors or foot soldiers of
any nationality or ethnic group then you
can put together a really huge military
and that's exactly what the Persians did
it's what the Romans did and in their
own way it's what you know jenga's
condit now what happens when you move to
the modern era beginning with the Dutch
Republic is that having the biggest army
is no longer the secret to global
dominance suddenly with colony
you know spices in the far-east gold and
the Americas suddenly commerce and
innovation and technology become you
know play a much bigger role and the way
to become the way to pull in the best
and brightest from all of the world is
no longer just conquering them and then
an Xing the territory and then being
tolerant but rather it's by turning
yourself into an immigration magnet and
that's exactly what the Dutch Republic
did and I think this may be again not so
well known to Americans but the Dutch
came to power in an era where it was
just religious warfare all over this is
just after the Crusades and all over
Europe it was religious warfare
Catholics against Protestants
Protestants against Catholics and what
the Dutch Republic did in its
foundational Charter was to actually
declare freedom of religion and at that
point it suddenly became a haven for
some of the most persecuted but also
some of the most entrepreneurial groups
in the world at that time actually
people from all over Europe but in
particular two groups were very
important and they were both fleeing the
Inquisition and Habsburgs persecution
and one group was the the Jews who had
been expelled from Spain and Portugal
and at the time these Jews included some
of the wealthiest people in the world
financiers Bank rollers of armies that
can control the diamond trade and the
rich trades and they had this huge
global trading network actually that
they brought to Holland the second group
that was pivotal to Holland's rise were
Protestants who brought with them
basically textile technology from
Antwerp and Bruges and just really the
most advanced technology of their time
and the Habsburgs lost it
I mean persecuting Habsburg Empire just
lost all these great people their cities
were depopulated everybody moved right
into Holland and the Dutch cities their
population exploded they suddenly became
the industrial leaders of the world they
became the financial leaders of the
world and then they came to control this
global trading network because they
dominated the Seas it was really navel
power that became the secret to global
dominance at that point and they really
for about 50 years
controlled the oceans this is raising a
question maybe we should come back to at
some point which is how long can have
hyper power lasts because the hyper
powers you're talking about don't seem
to have a long shelf life compared to
empires but let's hold that for a moment
because there's a good segue here to
America of course the place for the
people we call the pilgrims lived before
they came to America was was the
Netherlands wasn't it yes they fled
England to the Netherlands and then they
came to the United States and it was it
was it for the very reasons that you
have just been talking about is it for
the freedom I think in theory Holland
had religious freedom for a long time
but I do think that the United States
eventually replaced the European powers
as the land land of opportunity the
nation with the reputation for being the
most open and tolerant in the world but
the the the the people who did become
the pilgrims they had originally gone to
the Netherlands from England yes because
absolutely well now let's look at
America which is the the newest hyper
power and can you give us say a potted
history of America again as it plays in
with this theme of Tolerance how does
tolerance make America okay well if I'm
right that the ability at tolerance and
the ability to pull in the world's best
and brightest is the secret to global
dominance then in a sense the United
States has always had a leg up I mean
we're a nation of immigrants were the
first nation of immigrants to become a
hyper power and I actually make the case
that the secret to America's success has
always been really this ability not
militarism or aggression or imperialism
which we had of course but this was
really the first principle tolerance so
Verret from the very beginning even with
the founders Benjamin Franklin Thomas
Jefferson they all realized that America
needed technology so right from the very
beginning the 1780s
60s they were actively recruiting the
best glassblowers like best gunpowder
makers the best industrialists from
Europe and they were trying to recruit
them to the United States and uh that
was actually pivotal you know these
constant stream of immigrants was
pivotal to our Industrial Revolution
westward expansion again immigrants
played a crucial role it wasn't these
people it's not that all the immigrants
we have had were always once with
technology I mean just the opposite we
pulled in some of the poorest people
from Europe who were just looking for
the land of opportunity but these
immigrants filled a void as Americans
moved west there were these cities that
became empty you know and so in the 19th
century it was poor Irish poor Germans
poor Scandinavians who settled the
Northwest who worked in the mines
who built the railroads built the Erie
Canal and so they were really important
for westward expansion and then
immigrants also played that a central
and are winning the atomic bomb race I
think this part is a well-known story
Einstein and the maybe half dozen great
physicists who Jeremy yes who really
without which it's not clear we would
have won the race for the atomic bomb
they were all fleeing Nazi persecution
and they mostly came to the United
States and I think that was a direct as
a direct result of that you know we were
able to win the Second World War and
finally I think our domination of the
computer age in Silicon Valley were in
very very large parts direct
contributions of immigrants you you seem
to be talking when it comes to this
notion of tolerance in some ways in a
similar fashion to the way you were
talking with about the Mongols which was
the willingness and ability to absorb
what was needed from the outside but
isn't there a also a social component to
this that is crucial in terms of
assimilation it may be that something in
the United States did is something that
the Mongols didn't do which was as
people came to America
we not only
took the talents but we also made people
into something Americans so this society
building function might be something
different and advantageous but I'm just
asking I think that's the most in some
ways the most important piece of the
puzzle because it goes to your earlier
question which is how long can hyper
powers last and most past hyper powers
just couldn't do this they couldn't
create some sort of overarching
political identity that held all the
peoples together so the ancient Persians
they conquered Greeks and Egyptians but
there was no those people didn't feel
Persian they didn't feel loyalty the
Persian Empire the only other Empire
that really successfully did this the
only other hyper power was Rome and
you're right one of the greatest
successes of the United States and again
this is all relative I mean we were
absolutely brutal to our Native American
populations we had slavery for a long
time but we have always had this
capacity to assimilate immigrants and
within one or two generations to make
them feel American and I'm going to come
back to that in just one moment we'll
take a short break and thank you
afterwards and several others c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts visit book TV org more with Amy
Chua and Colin Murphy in a moment
coming up on in-depth Nell Irvin painter
formerly the director of the African
American Studies program at Princeton
miss fader has authored six books
including standing at Armageddon journey
toward freedom and Sojourner Truth the
life a symbol Nell painter live on in
depth January 6th at noon Eastern
afterwards with Amy Chua and Cullen
Murphy
continues welcome back Amy Chua and
we're talking about your book day of
empire and you were just talking about
the way in which the United States has
over time been able to take so many
different kinds of people and make them
into something that is different from
what they were and there's a place in
your book
we're actually you write about this in a
very personal way one of the things I
like about your book is is that they're
your own personal voice does does come
through and I wonder if you could tell
us about your own experience as being a
you know a child of immigrants what it
was like for your family your parents
your grandparents who I think your
grandfather became a citizen at one
point because it speaks to this issue of
you know a modern hyper power it does it
does well my parents were both Chinese
are both Chinese but they grew up in the
Philippines and they were actually both
liberated by General MacArthur so back
in 1945 and my parents remember the day
of liberation the GIS that I dad was
there so we have we have a connection
that you didn't know I didn't they they
remember the GIS you know throwing out
cigarettes and cans of spam and they
just were so grateful so my parents my
father in particular was always
desperate to get to the United States
and he is a brilliant mathematician and
it was a dream come true when MIT gave
him a student fellowship and now my
father was from a rather a
business-oriented family in the
Philippines my mother was from a very
intellectual family and their parents
actually
his parents actually opposed the
marriage though my parents eloped to MIT
I don't think this part is in the book
but they elope to MIT but they arrived
like many other immigrants without any
money in fact they were so poor they had
only their student fellowships to live
on they were so poor they live for two
winters in Boston without heat they just
wore blankets around my mother told me
just to stay warm so I was born a couple
years afterwards and being born into a
family of immigrants is um well there
are certain patterns my parents always
expected a lot of me and my three
younger sisters so and when I tell my
friends about my childhood they think oh
that must've been a terrible childhood
you know I we couldn't go to our friends
houses to sleepover or even for to do
anything we came home every day we
drilled math and piano all afternoon
when my father came home we I brought
him his slippers and took off his shoes
put on two slippers we spoke Chinese and
English we have to just study all the
time at one point I tell the story I won
second place in the history contest and
I brought my parents to an award
ceremony and my father said to me
afterwards don't ever ever disgrace me
like that again and but people
misunderstand when I tell these stories
I actually had a fabulous childhood and
what I was trying to capture is that the
United States lets people kind of change
on their own terms and become Americans
in their own way
while we were drilling math on the side
we were also you know experimenting with
sloppy joes and tacos and Dairy Queen
and ballet lessons and Girls Scouts and
poetry lessons and we did you know
skiing and crabbing and my father wanted
to try everything so and people change I
forget that in America I think has a way
of changing people we eventually moved
to Berkeley California my father grew
his hair long he's became a professor at
Berkeley he started collecting wine we
began traveling all over the world
because he's a he's a scientist and yes
finally my grandfather we brought him
over on my mother's side he at the age
of 98 just before he died
was insistent that he become a US
citizen and he did really didn't need it
he had been a permanent resident for you
know 40 years but he really wanted to
take the test and that's what he did and
we had a big celebration and he said you
know we asked him why did you do that
grandpa and he said because this is the
greatest country everybody wants to be
an American well you've given us a kind
of you know the wonderful essence of
becoming American story and if you could
you know bottle it it's the you know
it's it's the kind of potion we'd want
to give everyone and it's it's our
idealized you you were very fortunate in
living the idealized version of this now
as you recount it in your book the the
various factors that you've been talking
about the willingness to absorb people
and technology the way America is able
to meld diversity into unity and so on
you know eventually results in the
current situation where we are the hyper
power militarily we spend more than the
rest of the world combined and combined
and so on so so let's just stipulate
that status quo for us right now and the
first question I have is as a hyper
power how are we different from other
hyper powers can you isolate one or two
things that we haven't talked about yet
that really set us apart if there are
yes the most important difference
between the United States and all
previous hyper powers is that we're a
democracy we are the first mature
democracy to become a hyper power in an
age where it's basically universally
recognized that nations have a right to
self-government and this actually poses
a lot of problems for the United States
from a strategic point of view so for
example the United States now dominates
not just Americans but you know people
all over the world feel dominated by the
u.s. hyper power now Rome did this to
Rome dominated Syrians and Scots and you
know people from Spain but Rome had an
such that the United States does not
have and that is that Rome could make
all these foreign people's it conquered
part of the Roman Empire and in fact it
was able to extend citizenship to elites
and even just common soldiers who had
served for 25 years so Rome was able to
make foreign peoples like Rome they felt
part of the Roman Empire they felt that
they were Romans they were proud of the
Roman Empire and the United States just
cannot do anything of the sort as a
democracy the United States has no
interest we don't try or want to make
foreign populations our subjects and
certainly not our citizens so when the
US government speaks of bringing
democracy to the Middle East they are
not envisioning you know letting the
people of Baghdad and Fallujah vote in
the next u.s. presidential elections so
we don't have a way of really forging
bonds or so far we haven't done a good
job of forging connections and bonds
that would make people that are dominant
by the United States feel goodwill in
cooperation or certainly not any
allegiance towards the United States
mm-hmm
what's your view as to whether such a
way exists well I am actually an
optimist I think that this makes two of
us we're both deluded here at this table
yeah I think the key I think I mean
going back to Rome why was it the
longest-lasting hyper power I think the
key was that Rome was fantastic at
making people all over the world feel
that if Rome prospered they to with
prosper that Rome had something to offer
them and I think that so far the United
States has done a terrible job at this I
think that you know we have not done a
good job persuading Venezuelans and
Bolivians and Burmese and Moroccans
that any of those people have a stake in
US success or us leadership and I think
that is a shame I don't think it has to
be that way we've done a lot of things
wrong and there's a lot to be worried
about right now
but the United States has actually done
a lot of good it's amazing for me it's
amazing that right now if you
take public opinion polls all over the
world you find that majorities in Europe
Australia Russia Canada all have a more
favorable view of China than they do of
the United States and that's a sounding
for me because China is an authoritarian
state they crush freedom of speech
they're doing all kinds of investment
with genocide perpetuating countries
like Sudan you know we've done a lot of
things wrong but we're not doing those
things and yet we have a much worst
public image globally so I think there
are concrete things I don't think it's
all just marketing an image but I think
that there if we have the right
framework and the right mentality I
think that the u.s. can do better I'm
going to come back to this you know in a
moment but I'd like to focus just for a
second because so much of your thesis
really turns on this tolerance versus
intolerance trajectory and you know
there's a tolerance in the way you
define it is why powers rise and
intolerance is why powers fall so let's
look at the intolerance side of this
right now and first as with regards the
United States where are we at this if
you're if the subject is the annals of
Tolerance where where is the United
States right now are we in a good place
is the vector heading the right way well
I think we're at a place where we should
worry but I wouldn't necessarily be
alarmist I mean if you look at our own
history we've always had bursts of
xenophobia and nativism so it's not the
first time that you hear
anti-immigration sentiments and I mean
first I should say that I think it's
important to get rid of certain straw
man you know we do have new threats
right now I mean of course national
security has to come first and of course
you we have to be able to restrict
immigration you can't let everybody in
but having said that I do think there is
some cause for concern you know there
are people who are really trying to go a
lot further and
again the optimist of me one thing I see
in studying American history is how many
times we've been able to overcome this
it's often at these moments of weakness
and insecurity that suddenly there's an
you know this inflammation of
scapegoating it's their fault they're
taking our jobs we need to shut down but
we've always been able to overcome that
and again it's part of the sort of
American identity you know they're I
think that American identity is all
about being an open nation an open
confident nation so the question is
right now are we at a turning point is
there something different about the
calls is there something post 9/11 maybe
we've reached a point where it's we
people feel we really have too many
immigrants and we really will see a
stark turn and I think it's an open
question I mean I hope that we're not
again I think it's important to realize
that there's a lot of common ground I
mean of course the national security has
to come first but I do think that there
is a danger that if we turn our back on
the formula that is always served as
well that is if we suddenly become a
xenophobic country or one that tries to
pick good immigrants as opposed to bad
immigrants I think that's really
dangerous I don't think that's been
really our formula in the past you know
we've always taken in grudgingly
sometimes waves and waves and that
people have assimilated that doesn't
mean I'm talking not talk about illegal
immigrants but just waves of immigrants
that in the past people have said those
people can't be Americans they're
unassembled Italians Irish Germans and
you know we've always been able to
handle that and you know it may take
time but that's I think that's the
question to look for mostly you're
talking mostly you have been talking
just now about immigration but you can
imagine other fronts where the Tolerance
question comes up to I mean for instance
civil rights and then more more
problematically and in a way in a way
that's I think hotter these days
religion and it's not hard to see
looking around
the country that on religious issues in
particular both with regard to domestic
issues that come up whether it's
marriage and and so on or whether its
international the the so-called threat
of Islam Oh fascism that religious
tolerance is on the is kind of in play
these days in a way that it hasn't been
for a long time is that is that your
view maybe would do you rank religion in
there along with immigration absolutely
if you look at the history of the United
States and other hyper powers it's
amazing how often I mean how crucial
religious tolerance has been you know
that's actually been the key and we are
actually a country that was founded on
religious tolerance we weren't always
ethnically and racially tolerant
actually for most of our history we
weren't until after the civil rights
revolution but from the beginning we
really were a real relatively
religiously tolerant country and in fact
our early documents are fascinating the
founders were absolutely insistent on
not having um you know any religious
requirements in our Constitution you
know it was really foundational so I
think if we are to turn our back on that
that would be a surefire way to decline
again you know it's not clear that where
you are at that turning point there's
always been a lot of variety in this
country always been a lot of hot debate
and you know it'll be interesting to see
where we go but I think it you're right
it's both on the international front and
domestically so I for example will be
completely opposed to redefining this
country on the basis of religion to say
that we are a Protestant nation I mean
anybody can become a Protestant nation
and we are that's just never been the
United States at least from from my
point of view it's been you know and
ethnically and religiously neutral
identity that I think has really been
the secret to being able to assimilate
all these different people and you know
make them really feel like Americans let
me ask a kind of a troglodytes question
so you have to understand that I'm in
troglodyte mode here when it when it
comes to something like intolerance
just on a practical level what is bad
about intolerance what does what does
being intolerant do to you well that's
such a complicated question because
first of all we are no longer in ancient
times and we now use a different
definition of tolerance it is part of
the fundamental rights of people it's
linked up with equality so I think that
there are inherent bad things if you are
if you practice intolerance you know if
you are a bigot
there are personal costs and it's it's
bad for lots of reasons that actually I
don't get into so much in my book
because in my book I really
ironically of sort of talking about
tolerance in almost a strategic sense
and that's I'm asking about it too what
is the strategic downside of intolerance
of the strategic downside is that you
basically in the lose your ability to
pull in the world's best and brightest I
think some people today think that if we
say they want to have their cake and eat
it too is that they say you know maybe
we should just take in the good
immigrants Engineers from certain you
know from from Korea but shut down other
aspects and I just don't think that
that's possible I think that destroys
the formula we I think the secret to
America's success has been our
reputation that we are the most tolerant
and open nation in the world and that's
why you know an engineer from Nepal will
want to come here because it's the land
of opportunity for him or you know
somebody of the best mathematician from
you know as a small island in the
Caribbean will want to come here and
it's that ability I think that has
created the energy that has made America
so successful and I think if we were to
try to pick and choose now or to really
cut down on immigration I think there
will be a direct cost and that is we
will lose our technological and
competitive edge or economic competitive
edge and our technological edge directly
translates into our military edge I mean
there was no you know the only reason we
are so dominant militarily is because of
the microchip and all of Silicon Valley
which again I mean fifty two point five
percent of all technology startups in
Silicon Valley between 1995 and 2005 had
one immigrant
a key founder so it's you know the the
role of immigrants is quite dramatic you
have some classic stories in your book
of societies that shot themselves in the
foot
with either an arrow or or a gun because
they actually did close themselves off
intolerance did them in and in other
words and I think Spain is is it is a
great example and I wonder if you could
just quickly give us just because the
the the moral lessons here are are so
clear just to give us a quick review of
what a couple of those societies are
okay you have a chapter on almost like
near misses Yeah right and three
societies I chose to talk about one is
actually the Ming Dynasty empire of
China that at one point it looked like
they could take over Europe made by far
the greatest ships but they decided
fearful of outsiders and foreigners to
completely shut down and they burned all
their ships and became very xenophobic
and clothed so they never achieved
anything close to global dominance I
talked about Spain which again it looked
like they had a shot at world dominance
in the 15th century and the thing they
did that really was a bad strategic move
was they expelled all their Jews not
just their Jews and they also then
decided that they also needed to expel
people who had converted from Judaism to
Christianity then they wanted to expel
their Muslims and people who had
converted from Islam to Christianity
then they wanted to expel their Jesuits
so expulsion is not a great formula for
trying to become a hyper power and I
also talked about the Ottoman Empire
that was incredibly tolerant during it's
golden age but really just descended and
into intolerance and fragmented in the
most kind of terrible and brutal way you
know towards the end of the Empire yeah
those are those are certainly object
lessons we we ought to be aware of one
of the points that comes through your
book I think is that although the United
States is the
you know the current hyperpower and and
probably the greatest hyperpower ever if
you just look at the power across the
board and in so many different different
ways that maybe were at some sort of a
tipping point you said a couple of times
already that you're an optimist but
nonetheless you hold this tipping point
issue out because it's something that we
need to be to be aware of and and I
think you do it with great cogent see I
think we probably are one of those
points the great the great bugbear of
hyper powers is fragmentation and you
talk in a number of places about some
sort of you say for lack of a better
word there's a glue that holds hyper
powers together and I'm sure the glue is
different in different places at
different times can you talk a little
bit about the glue as it exists in
America right now maybe and maybe just
quickly tell us what the glue was
someplace else okay I found realize it's
a sticky ya know one of the most
interesting things I found from you know
looking at past hyper powers is that
every hyper power in history has faced
the same fundamental problem the one I
call the problem of glue and by that I
mean finding ways to have connections
and forging goodwill and cooperation and
ideally loyalty between the hyper power
and all the people that you dominate and
again most hyper powers of the past
could not do this so they just kind of
held together these huge empires with
sheer military force and that's within a
very short time most of them just
disintegrated now when you fast-forward
to the United States I actually think
that the United States has had
incredibly strong glue internally for
some reason the American identity has
been very absorptive American culture
people within one generation want to be
Americans and I think that the part of
the secret to that is precisely because
it is an ethnically and religiously
neutral identity so as long as you
embrace American values speak English I
actually think that's very important you
have to be able to participate in the
political sphere to
part you know of the united states but
as long as you believe in the values of
the constitution and are willing to
follow the values than anybody of any
skin color of any background can become
an American and it's been actually I
think a very effective glue there are
dangerous signs that that might be
unraveling if people want to replace
that identity with another formulation I
think that's dangerous but my own view
is that our one of our greatest problems
is really visa vie the rest of the world
I think the United States as a
democratic hyper power right now really
needs to figure out a way to you know
people talk about hearts and minds but
it's even more than that it's it we need
to find ways to convince the rest of the
world that they have a stake in American
success and an American leadership
otherwise you know nobody's going to
want it and that's where we don't have
the glue we can't offer the rest of the
world citizenship from we can't make
them all part of an American Empire I
mean it doesn't seem that we want to do
that so we need to find alternative
mechanisms and I think some of those may
be economic but I think this is the this
is where people should be thinking you
know how can we let other people feel
that they have a stake and that's where
I think the glue you know that's the
hardest question speaking of the rest of
the world you do have a chapter as I
recall I think it's called the
challenger's about some of the other you
don't call them hyper power wannabes I
don't think but but that might be one
way to think of them and I'm not sure
that you think that they actually will
be hyper powers India would be one China
would be one what what does the future
hold for them I do talk about the
European Union and Europe China and
India as you know the rivals that people
worry about a lot these days and
interestingly if my thesis is right that
the way to become a hyper power the only
way you can do it in modern times is by
being able to pull in the best and
brightest from every part of the world
then actually I think that China much as
people are worried I think that China
can continue and will continue to do
extremely well economically it's doing
lots of things
right it will grow and become stronger
but I actually think that it can't
become a hyper power and that's because
China is sort of the opposite of an
immigrant society you know it's an
ethnically defined nation and you for
example still see large numbers of
gifted Chinese engineers and scientists
wanting to come to the United States to
become American citizens but you don't
see large numbers of European and
American engineers moving to China to
try to become Chinese citizens did you
see a lot moving to India you do but I
don't know if they're trying to become
Indian citizens so that's the key it's
you know you could have multinationals
who are located in China but they're
still Americans you know they are not
really they're not trying to be throwing
Chinese citizens so there are I don't
know what the future holds one
possibility is that Europe and China and
India could or Russia could continue to
grow so that they become superpowers you
know or great powers not superpowers I
don't think but superpowers to a certain
point that the u.s. Falls from its hyper
power status and that we go back to a
world where there are just you know
several powers of roughly equal strength
a multipolar world right you know and
that would be quite different from what
we have and I think it's an open
question whether that would be better or
worse for the world or even better or
worse for the United States one of the
points I noticed is that as the meaning
of being a hyper power has changed in
some ways modern hyper powers can't get
all the benefits that past hyper powers
could but they suffer all the costs so
you know we can't just plunder we can't
just plunder we can't just siphon all of
our eyes quietly anyway and even that is
very very difficult I mean you know when
Rome conquered Romania it got a million
pounds of silver and we just can't do
that they didn't have deficit spending
now it is the you know the the the costs
and the advantages of being a hyper
power certainly do do change over over
time well let me ask you one last since
we've just got about a minute left
last question so let's say you even
though we are a democracy that you're
the empress of the of this particular
hyper power and you could you could make
America do two or three things that you
think would be in its own self-interest
what would you have us do well I think
the most important thing is to remember
the formula that has made America so
great and it's I think not been
militarism or invasion or imperialism or
exclusion or arrogance but it's really
simply been tolerance that is this
having the reputation as the most open
and receptive nation in the world and
that's been why we've been able to
attract people from every corner of the
world throughout our history and I think
that's what's giving us our
technological edge and our military edge
so I would say in this moment I feel
that we're in a moment of a lot of
anxiety uh you know maybe after 9/11 our
borders but really not to give in to
sort of this fear and insecurity I mean
even on a personal level with
individuals it's some of the ugliest
moments are when people are afraid that
you give in to kind of scapegoating a
bad tendency so I would say you know we
have a good formula and if we continue
that formula there's really no reason to
think that we can't compete as we always
have
well one like just one last question I
want to make sure that we had time to
get this in so whether we stay a hyper
power or not if yes no answer are we the
last hyper power
I don't know I wish I could give a
better answer but I don't know we may be
because there are not many other great
immigrant societies out there and in the
modern day I don't think there's any
other way to incorporate the world's
best and brightest without being you
know really a magnet and emigrate